I'm dr. Radford Bane's of the
information service our thanks to this
theater for making this time available
to us perhaps some of you have wondered
what is the world's most vicious animal
lion tiger rhino no the most vicious
animal in the world is a tiny one no
larger than that the killer shrew I'm
gonna show you some of them they look
like mice don't they but they aren't
these little fiends must eat three times
their own body weight every day are they
starved to death they attack every
living creature regardless of size
including human beings and they consume
everything bones flesh marrow everything
and the blurryness shrew is deadly
poisonous shrews like these have been
known to attack a pack of wolves and
devour them without a trace you can
understand our concern for Public Safety
when I tell you that there have been
recent sightings of giant killer shrews
in Alaska we urge that you report to
your local authorities at once any
sighting of a Giant Killer shrew
you